so then i got an opportunity to get a
store on melrose i met a guy he was like
hey i got a store you know with the
corona i only gotta pay 25 of the rent
right now i don't want to be in here
we're good until like for like six
months if you give me six months worth
of rent you know the rent is like
probably like six seven thousand just
give me like 25 3 500
a month and i'll let you keep it but you
got to pay it all up front
so i'm like all right well i'm gonna
give him like 15 bands
15 minutes i was supposed to be good for
like five six months you know what i
mean second month they start cutting the
lights off in the building on melrose
[ __ ] they like they locked the front
door changed the locks on the front door
you know what i mean but this is still
corona so you really technically can't
lock people out
you know what i mean
but then it just got to a point where i
had so much inventory in there and they
just like look after this date we're
going to lock the doors and have this
this was a letter from the sheriff's
we're going to lock the doors and you're
not going to be able to get anything out
so that was like february i was
literally only there for like a month
but within that month i probably made
like a million dollars wow just being on
melrose
jesus like probably two months to be
exact two months by the third month i
was like i gotta get up out of here you
know what i mean so
by the third month it's like [ __ ] i
really gotta leave um i'm looking for
different locations i'm searching
you know they're still putting trying to
cut the lights off they got the landlord
it's coming down
you know so by exactly like the fourth
month i found downtown
i got signed the lease for downtown
right next to the parking lot that i
used to sell out of so it was all right
there oh it kind of worked out yeah so
then i got that spot then like once i
got that spot a week later somebody hit
me back for a spot on melrose
another spot on melrose so then i take
that one too